[Music]
if you don't know
anything about medieval art you might
reasonably assume
old illustrated texts featured basic
depictions of historical and religious
figures
but medieval art is overflowing with
absurdity
particularly when it comes to depictions
of medieval beasts
beyond the dragons and unicorns you
might be familiar with
is a truly insane world of lesser-known
monsters
which stretched the imagination with
their utter bizarreness
so today we're going to take a look at
the top 10 strangest of these creatures
bearing in mind it was exceedingly
difficult to cut this down to just 10.
number 10 monopod mythological creatures
with a single leg ending in a massive
foot
monopod's name comes from a greek term
aptly meaning
one foot medieval artists often drew
them lying down
with their foot stretched over their
head this comes from a legend that the
monopods have a habit of protecting
themselves from the sun using the shade
cast by their foot
sort of like a natural umbrella
number nine monaecon though at first
glance these mythic creatures resemble
ordinary bulls the banay khan was said
to eject large amounts
of caustic excrement at hunters while
medieval texts often communicated moral
lessons through fictitious beasts the
banaycon seems to have no symbolic
meaning whatsoever
if anything it only shows lowbrow humor
hasn't changed much over the centuries
number eight sea monk ducking just
slightly out of the medieval period for
a creature i had to include
the sea monk is an organism allegedly
captured off the danish coast
which outwardly resembled a monk in a
habit
supposedly the account claimed the
animal's resemblance to a monk was just
a coincidence
the creature had the inner workings of
an ordinary fish and just happened to
superficially resemble a monk on the
outside
number 7 salamander this next one might
seem like an odd inclusion since the
amphibious salamander isn't mythical at
all
but medieval legends of salamanders were
let's say
a little off from the real-life organism
alchemists believes salamanders were
fireproof which is strange enough
but many depictions of salamanders
deviate wildly from their actual
appearance
why so many medieval artists assigned
hair and human faces to salamanders is
unfortunately largely unclear
[Music]
number 6 amphis bien getting its name
from the greek term amphis meaning both
ways
and bien meaning to go this rather
amusing monster was a serpent with two
opposing heads
according to legend the unfortunate
reptile had difficulty moving around
due to the dual minds tugging it in
different directions
number 5 churale the only creature on
this list originating in russia shirale
is a long-fingered humanoid from folk
tales who dwells in the woods
though not too far off from trolls or
goblins what makes girali so unusual is
its behavior
according to legends shirali lures the
unlucky into thickets where he tickles
them to death
something about that is genuinely
unsettling
number four snails one of my personal
favorites
like the salamander medieval snails are
based on their real-life counterparts
but deviate wildly from what you'd find
in nature
manuscripts portray snails as enormous
weapon-wielding juggernauts
menacing knights and helpless villagers
hilariously historians aren't entirely
sure why so many margins of medieval
texts feature these super-sized mollusks
with theories ranging from political
propaganda to the snails representing
the slow but inevitable approach of
death which awaits us all
number three lemmies headless creatures
with faces on their chests the
intelligent and communal blemis are
another one of my favorites
more so than the other entries on this
list medieval european scholars believe
the blemish to be more than the stuff of
fables many believe the blemish were a
real species of humanoid living in
other parts of the world to the point
where they're featured on several maps
just sort of hanging out
[Music]
number two the vegetable lamb of tartary
we're really in the strange stuff now
the vegetable lamb is a legendary plant
which sprouted fruit identical in
appearance to sheep
the sheep even contained blood and bones
despite being
plants holy roman emperor historian
sigmund von herbert sign
even went as far as to say he'd heard
from too many credible sources to doubt
the plant's existence
although herbert stein was obviously
mistaken modern scholars actually have a
theory that the legends
origin stems from widely circulated
misinterpretations
of cotton plants pretty interesting
stuff
number one grillus i simply
couldn't resist putting this little guy
at the very top
what you see is what you get with this
one a pair of legs topped with a head
parading in packs around the margins of
medieval manuscripts
they're simple but there's something so
fundamentally absurd about the gorillas
especially considering their origin is
almost completely
unknown what an incredible albeit
inexplicable creation
[Music]
and that's where our list comes to an
end i hope you had fun going on this
journey through the bizarre world of
medieval monsters with me
please consider subscribing and leaving
this video a like if you enjoyed the
content
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
foreign